امبارح ضرب زلزال قوي كمان
سته نقطه اربعه صار وبعدين صار خمسه
ثمانيه حسيته
الف سلامه
هاي الموضوع متى يمكن ان تصمدوا في هذه
الخيام والله كثير صعب الله لا يوقع حدا
كتير كتير صعب اللي بعيش بيعرف لكن في
مساعدات توصلكم على الاقل الاكل ساخن وكل
شيء الاكل ما مشكله يا اخي هلا
القدر
امبارح بنسب من الساعه خمسه اكثر من 50
مره تفكر في المستقبل القريب او البعيد
كيف ستكون الحياه
واضح الف سلامه عليكم ان شاء الله اذا هذه
شهاده احد قاطنيه هذه المخيمات حول ما جرى
او مسلسل الرعب المتجدد معهم في هذه
المدينه المتعرضه لهزات ارتداديه ثلاث حتى
زلزال المدمر الذي ضرب امس حوالي عشرين
هزه هناك اليوم قرار
بتحويل نحو 100 الف طالب من هذه المناطق
المتضرره نحو مناطق اخرى نشاهد الان هناك
بعض الاشخاص ربما يغادرون حتى هذه الخيام
التي مثل ما قلت سابقا ربما لا يشعرون
الان بامان في هذه المناطق ممكن اسالك
وين رايح
سنحاول ترجمه ما يقوله بمساعده احدث
منتقلين الى ولايه ثانيه لماذا
يعني
واحد قريبك بولايه ثانيه هل تشعر بالخوف
بعد الزلزال الاخير ربما انتم تخوفتوا
تريدون المغادره
البقاء هنا لمساعده الناس هنا للانقاذ لكن
هو يودي الاطفال
يعني تريد ان تنقذ اطفالك من هذه المدينه
انت متخوف انه بيصير شيء
نعم نعم الف سلامه عليك يقول بانه يفر
باطفاله وعائلته الى مدينه اخرى بعيدا عن
هاتاي نشاهد وهو يحمل الان مقتنيات هؤلاء
الاطفال لكنه متشبت بارضه يقول بانه سيعود
الى هاتاي ويبقى هنا لمساعده المتضررين من
هذا الزلزال نشاهد عبد القادر لو سمحت لي
يعني اغلب منازل انطاكيا او بل هاتاي
بصوره عامه مدمره جزئيا او كليا لكن هناك
حديث عن بعض المنازل الصامته الصامته في
هذه الازمه هل استطاع سكانها العوده اليها
والمبيت فيها
قد يكون ذلك قبل ثلاثه ايام وقبل حدوث
الزلزال الكبير الذي ضرب امس المنطقه لكن
الان اكاد اجزم ان لا احد بداخل بيته على
الاقل هنا في حيث تجولت عده شوارع وعده
يعني احياء شاهدنا يعني كان هناك يعني شبه
مدينه اشباح سواء ليلا او حتى اليوم صباحا
لا وجود لاشخاص انا اول مره الان اقابل
اناس بهذا المخيم هناك هجران لهذه البيوت
فعلا هناك بعض العمارات تعد على الاصابع
تبدو كانها صامده ولكن بها تشققات وبها
سنشاهد من من هذا الجانب في عمارات هاي
عماره مثلا
بالوسط عماره غير مكتمله الانجاز
شاهدتها قبل قليل بها تصدعات لكن طبعا
الخبراء هم من سيقررون ان كانت صالحه
للعيش ام لا نشاهد هذه الصوره الان وهو
ياخذ مرحبا هذه لعبه ابنك
اخذ اخذ معك لعبه ابنك هذه البلد شوف صوره
معبره جدا يعني هناك تشبث بالحياه حتى وسط
الدمار والزلزال والموت ورائحه الموت التي
تحيط بكل مكان هناك نوع من التشبت بالحياه
في كل مع كل مقابله نجريها مع هؤلاء الناس
مع كل مشهد نراه مع كل اعمال تطوعيه
ومحاولات لانقاذ من هم تحت الانقاض وان
حدث ذلك سيكون معجزه بعد كل هذه المده
الزلزال الذي ضرب بالامس قضى على سته
اشخاص للاسف
ولحد الان لم تعلن السلطات عن عدد
الموجودين تحت الانقاذ ونحن نحاول او نبحث
عن اماكن ان كانت فيها انقاذ لحد الان لم
نلحظ ذلك